hi i'm steven yun and i'm going
undercover on the internet
this is actually me
[Music]
first up twitter
how was getting naked with conan o'brien
every bit as magical
as you could imagine very tall
pale kind man getting naked with you
that's like
it's like up there you know bucket list
stuff
next why is minari under a
foreign film category when it is filled
in the u.s and produced by asian
americans
i thought foreign film means you know a
film from a foreign country
hashtag golden globes i don't know
you know i mean i think rules and
institutions
fail us i'm just glad that i get to be
part of a film
that challenges those ideas and presents
the ways in which these rules and
institutions misunderstand
our actual lives america is made up of
a lot of different things including
different cultures different people
different points of view
and that's kind of what makes this
country so beautiful i wouldn't know
the answer to your question um
you should ask them replied
i miss you on walking dead tears were
shed at your demise were you
disappointed you didn't get to leave the
show as a walker
no being on that show for seven years i
saw
what it took to be a zombie on that show
and
um i just don't have what it takes
mostly the contacts seem like they hurt
so i'm very glad that i didn't do that
next how would you describe working with
bong joon ho
compared to other american directors or
was there even a big difference
hashtag okja director bong is a singular
entity
he is like no one else the best way to
describe it for me
was in the frame he kind of has an idea
of where
people fit uh physically in that space
and then you're kind of free to be your
character
within like the parameter that he's
given to you
i love directors like that where you
just trust them completely outright
i read it no seriously it's
it's actually me a little random but
stephen younes
improved his korean by leaps and bounds
over the last several years i don't know
if he was being formerly coach
slash taught or if it's just a natural
result of
all the korean projects he's taken up
but his accent is barely noticeable in
this trailer
thank you yes my korean did improve
and it was because i got to work in
korea
but i will say uh there was conscious
choice
of making my character speak
bad korean and then with me
i worked really hard to try to make sure
that i sounded like a korean american
person who had spent some time away from
his motherland and so
korean variety shows really did nothing
for my accent
[Music]
back to twitter did ben murder hemi
is he a serial killer or not me and my
girl have been debating over this
and our heads are about to explode out
of confusion please
tell oh no director lee
told me halfway through filming that i
needed to
pick whether ben was a good person
misunderstood or a bad person
and uh i did and then
he asked me what i chose and i said i
wasn't
gonna tell him and then that that's
pretty much it
nobody knows only i know
posted i tried real minari about five
years ago
it has a unique taste uh
swampy i know many older koreans love
this stuff did you eat this stuff as a
kid i prefer cilantro though
not soapy taste to me i hope to see the
film soon
cool brian um this is where i'll be
honest
as a korean american kid i don't always
know what i'm eating
you know i just eat whatever my mom has
made so
uh i don't know if i've explicitly eaten
minari or not
i don't remember any swampy flavor in
general
with korean food yeah that's that's kind
of
you know my diaspora reality next
youtube
[Music]
there's something very randall parky
about the director
oh that means i love randall park um
what does that mean uh also how are he
and steven semi related so isaac
is my wife's cousin but the cool part
was was the first year i ever met my
wife in chicago
she took me to go see his first film
munyan rongabo
which is incredible i just never
connected any dots of trying to work
together with him or
even even saw that as an option until i
was presented with this beautiful script
that he wrote
and i'm very blessed for it he's a
wonderful person
and if you mean that randall park is a
wonderful person and that's that's why
he
seems randall parking replied
[Music]
can you two do another travel show
together i loved you two traveling in
korea
i don't know you'd have to ask conan you
know he's a busy man
i mean i would love to that'd be so fun
next
[Music]
why does he identify as a second
generation kid i thought he was born
in korea i grew up calling myself a 1.5
generation kid because i was born in
korea
and i immigrated here so i find myself
in a very specific way
more twitter hi no idea if you're in
charge of your own twitter or if you
answered to questions but i heard you
say your name wasn't actually stephen
but hang yup as as pronounced
wikipedia says your name was hung yup is
hung up pronounced
hanging up or is wikipedia wrong
i i just said how it's pronounced it's
hung up
i don't know how you heard an h maybe
you should
yeah that's it
hey i'm from regina saskatchewan when
you lived in regina sketchman what did
you think of it
i was too young to form like deep deep
memories of that place
actually it's kind of sad my maternal
grandmother passed away
when we were there and i just have this
eerie memory of being taken to this
house
where all my aunts and uncles gathered
and they were mourning
my grandmother's death that's how i
remember saskatchewan i'm sorry
replied are you still an accidental
expert at bowling
it's not by accident that's like decade
of church league bowling domination
next quora
how can i have a hollywood career as an
asian what steps do i take
first and foremost don't forget that
you're
also a human that has
their own unique reality you should just
try to find out
what is uniquely yours and speak from
that place
i don't think any actor's journey you
can replicate so get out of the box
posted all right uh that's it
uh for me thank you guys for the
questions i'm
gonna get off the internet for for a
while
thanks